We've been talking about equations for functions that are inverses of one
another, and also points that lie on them. And we have seen one graph of two
inverse functions, but I think that it would be great if we could focus on the
graphical part a little bit more. So, here I've drawn for you two functions
that we were working with earlier. We started off with f of x equals 3x minus
1, and we found it's inverse, which is f inverse of x equals 1 3rd times x plus
1. Of course, now from the last quiz, we also know that f is the inverse of f
inverse. But, I'll keep with this notation for now. This is pretty tricky, but
how are these lines related to one another? I'll give you some choices to make
things a bit simpler. Which of these choices properly completes this sentence?
The graph of f inverse is the reflection in the what of the graph of f? Your
choices are x-axis, y-axis, or the line y equals x. Think about what it would
look like to reflect f in each of these lines, and then see if one of those
pictures matches the graph of f inverse.